alors voilà nous sommes bien installés
sur la scène du prisme à Élancourt nous
sommes en compagnie de Thomas perron
Arnaud bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le
directeur de ce théâtre avec vous on va
parler de cette nouvelle saison
culturelle qui arrive pour l'année 2023
2024 première question comment est-ce
qu'elle a été imaginée pensée cette
programmation culturelle
en rapport avec la saison qui vient de
se passer où on avait effectivement
changé un peu le paradigme sur sur la
programmation on était plutôt sur du one
man show des comédies du théâtre de la
musique donc on est on s'est basé un peu
sur le c'était Matic là puisque ça très
très bien fonctionné puisqu'on était sur
un taux de remplissage de 82 % ce qui
est quand même plutôt très bien post
covid donc on s'est basé effectivement
sur sur cette thématique là alors après
nous on est aussi dépendant des
tourneurs des productions en fonction
des spectacles qui sont proposés donc
voilà donc effectivement on fait un
choix par rapport à ce qu'on nous
propose on imaginons que ça puisse
plaire à notre public ce qui a priori
était le cas la saison dernière alors
dans les grands rendez-vous qui nous
attendent j'ai noté tap Factory c'est un
show avec 7 personnes ce sera le 7
octobre je vous propose de regarder un
extrait on en parle tout de suite après
[Musique]
alors on le voit bien sur ces images
c'est un véritable show tap Factory il y
a une histoire derrière où c'est
simplement qui a été créé et qui a
tourné dans le monde entier et c'est
très chapellé ce qu'on fait c'est où il
y a un mélange de claquettes c'est très
très basé sur les claquettes la
percussion voilà donc c'est un spectacle
je publie en fait c'est vraiment on a
décidé de commencer la saison avec ce
spectacle là pour que les gens puissent
venir en famille en fait c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment l'idée que ça soit
quelque chose d'assez attractif assez
percutant un peu onirique avec un très
beau décor des très belles lumières ça
fait partie de notre métier le spectacle
les lumières le décor le son voilà donc
on a vraiment choisi de commencer la
saison avec ce spectacle là en pensant
qu'effectivement ça ça regrouperait les
familles ce qui est aussi
une de nos missions c'est aussi de
pouvoir proposer des spectacles à des
prix attractifs pour les familles quand
on sort à deux trois quatre on essaie de
faire en sorte que le prix soit quand
même raisonnable voilà un autre
rendez-vous Marianne James elle est
connue notamment pour avoir participé à
la nouvelle star c'est une autrice une
interprète comment est-ce que vous avez
fait pour la faire venir aux prises
alors avant la nouvelle star moi je la
connaissais plutôt pour artiste parce
que j'ai eu un contrôle de nouvelles ça
mais effectivement je la connaissais
plus en tant qu'artiste sur son premier
sur son premier spectacle
personnage pétillant intéressant
très grande chanteuse et du coup là on
est sur un spectacle pareil qui est un
peu interactif puisqu'en fait c'est un
spectacle qui est en même temps musical
qui est drôle où il y a effectivement
cette interaction avec le public où elle
fait chanter des gens elle fait monter
des gens sur scène donc
l'idée quand même dans le spectacle
vivant c'est de pouvoir échanger c'est
quand même la base de du spectacle
vivant c'est quand même surtout ça et là
pour le coup ça fonctionne très bien
puisqu'effectivement c'est vraiment dans
un échange permanent avec le public
voilà et comment comment la on la repéré
parce que parce qu'elle est connue et
qu'effectivement elle a à la notoriété
qui la précède et puis elle a cette
espèce de d'énergie
ultra positive qui est le monde du
spectacle c'est aussi on a le droit
aussi d'avoir des spectacles de de cet
ordre là c'est à dire qu'il soit léger
intéressant voilà il faut faire des des
spectacles légers en ce moment c'est ça
que vous retenez ce que je retiens c'est
que ce que je retiens c'est que dans le
dans le théâtre et notamment dans le
nôtre on essaie de d'avoir une
proposition artistique qui soit assez
large ça veut dire qu'on peut faire
aussi bien de la comique ou du théâtre
avec des choses un peu plus classiques
un peu plus où il y a peut-être un peu
plus de réflexion mais ça n'empêche pas
effectivement d'avoir des choses qui
soient un peu plus populaires au sens
noble du terme et qui soit accessible au
plus grand nombre ça c'est quand même
l'idée principale du théâtre de le
prisme en fait c'est de pouvoir attirer
des gens pour se faire plaisir et en
fait absolument de faire en sorte que
des gens pour qui le théâtre l'ensemble
le théâtre soit pas forcément quelque
chose ou tiens je vais à l'hôtel nous
l'idée c'est de faire venir des gens
dans notre théâtre qu'aurai jamais
l'idée d'y aller avant voilà
James justement qui qui met du baume au
cœur qui fait rire je vous propose de
regarder un extrait de son spectacle en
1 il faut des poumons c'est l'usine qui
donne de l'air et ça remonte par la
trachée ça traverse le vibratteur là le
larynx qui émet un son pas très beau
d'ailleurs ça fait un peu ça les cordes
vocales comme ça et au dessus magie
magie troisième chose troisième étage de
la fusée le masque raisonnateur
l'amplificateur toute la tête et tout ça
ça fait une voix alors oui on n'est pas
tous égaux devant la voie l'humanité
nous a offert Maria Callas mais aussi
Carla Bruni
et donc elle sera le 3 février sur la
scène du prisme à Élancourt autre
one-man show comic Artus il y a beaucoup
d'humour cette cette saison au prisme il
y a beaucoup d'humour il y a pas que ça
évidemment mais il y a beaucoup d'humour
parce qu'on sait que ça a fonctionné et
puis très honnêtement à passer les deux
années voire deux années de poste covid
les gens avaient aussi envie de de
retrouver un peu le sourire d'avoir des
choses un peu légères alors on peut
avoir des choses légères et en même
temps ce que je vous disais précédemment
des choses un peu plus comme dirais-je
un peu plus fines ou peut-être un peu
plus intellectuel mais en tout cas
effectivement l'humour c'est c'est une
place importante de chez nous il faut
aussi que les salles se démarquent avec
une programmation que les gens
connaissent d'une année sur l'autre même
sans refaire tout le temps la même chose
chaque salle de la de l'agglo à sa
spécificité voilà donc effectivement
nous on a on a essayé effectivement de
d'avoir une programmation assez large
mais vous effectivement et l'humour la
comédie à une place importante
absolument et donc effectivement on va
avoir Artus alors Arthur c'est une
création le spectacle il est en création
mais on connaît le personnage je
reconnais cette reculence on connaît son
humour un peu incisif on touche aussi
certainement avec avec Artus un public
un peu plus jeune et c'est la première
fois on va faire un spectacle le
dimanche en fin d'après-midi d'accord
donc ça c'est une première mais parce
que ça ça pouvait pas se faire autrement
par rapport aux routines des des
productions donc voilà et on s'est dit
bah oui tiens dimanche à 18h ça peut
être sympa d'aller voir un spectacle
plutôt que de rester je sais pas à la
maison ou regarder la télé ou je sais
pas peut-être aller à la pêche sur ça
voilà donc l'idée c'était aussi de de
changer on essaie de on essaie
systématiquement changer de s'améliorer
de réfléchir à des nouveaux des nouveaux
projets des nouvelles choses au théâtre
en fait on travaille dans la culture on
essaie de d'être toujours à peu près
curseur et de d'essayer de changer les
choses alors on va parler de tête
justement quelques pièces seront jouées
forcément durant cette saison culturelle
il y a notamment changé l'eau des fleurs
qui a été nommé au Molière 2022 avec
l'actrice Caroline Rochefort qui a reçu
le titre de révélation féminine voilà et
donc là pour le coup quand on parlait de
la programmation on aussi du théâtre
parce que en fait une fois de plus quand
on fait par exemple Artus on va aussi
essayer de vendre aux gens qui viennent
voir Arthus on a aussi du théâtre
effectivement changer le des fleurs
c'est un livre qui a été vendu à 850 000
ou 900 000 exemplaires la pièce a été
montée après après le livre
effectivement avec une comment dire à
très très bon retour au niveau de la
presse et des spectateurs donc
effectivement aussi on a on a aussi ce
type de pièce qui alors on est plus du
tout effectivement dans dans l'humour
des choses comme ça on a des choses un
peu plus un peu plus fine ou il y a un
peu plus de réflexion et en même temps
et en même temps ça fait partie de notre
mission aussi de pouvoir aussi avoir des
choses de cet ordre là en fait voilà il
y aura aussi des des comédies notamment
au scalpel et une autre drôle de genre
avec Lionel Astier et Victoria Abril
alors là effectivement on est sur
quelque chose de complètement différent
mais en même temps dans le genre il y a
même si c'est une comédie il y a quand
même une réflexion derrière sur sur
l'identité enfin des choses comme ça
donc on peut faire de la comédie avec du
sens et quand les acteurs sont bons le
message habituellement passe assez
facilement et notamment par le biais du
rire donc voilà donc c'est ça c'est
effectivement c'est une pièce qui a qui
est à la fois drôle et en même temps qui
a du sens alors le programme culturel
est riche puisque vous avez aussi de la
musique avec notamment Chimène Badi qui
va venir célébrer les 60 ans de la
disparition d'Édith Piaf absolument et
on connaît pareil on connaît la
chanteuse on connaît ça ça prestance sa
façon d'interpréter les choses elle est
c'est une grande grande fan de de
d'Édith Piaf
effectivement c'était l'occasion du
rendre hommage on a un très très beau
spectacle un peu minimaliste avec des
très beaux décors mais par contre quand
vous avez des très bons chanteurs de de
cet ordre là ça suffit presque à eux
donc et on est ravis d'accueillir tous
ces artistes là parce qu'en fait
globalement l'idée aussi sur le prisme
c'est de pouvoir avoir une programmation
qu'on pourra retrouver à Paris avec des
facilités d'accès des prix raisonnables
en termes de de prix du billet quels
sont les prix justement quelle est la
fourchette si les gens prennent la carte
prise mais ils peuvent avoir sur
certains spectacles qui peuvent payer 12
euros sur d'autres qui peuvent payer 22
23 24 en tout cas c'est vrai que le côté
attractif de du prix du billet une fois
de plus par rapport aux familles des
choses comme ça et puis en plus on a la
facilité d'accès on a un bar on a de la
restauration on a des expositions on est
on est sur quelque chose qui est un peu
plus vivant et un peu plus un peu
différent de juste de la consommation
stricto sensus on est aussi dans
l'échange avec les gens avec notre
public on connaît qui nous connaissent
vous avez des habitués toujours des
fidèles effectivement nous notre
objectif c'est de recevoir les gens au
mieux de ce qu'on peut c'est pour ça que
chaque année on essaie d'avoir des
projets un peu nouveau on travaille avec
des artistes locaux pour les pour les
expositions puisque effectivement on a
un panel assez large dans la dans la
région et notamment sur
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines d'artistes
donc voilà donc systématiquement on
essaie déjà de travailler avec les
artistes locaux comme ce soir avec avec
Adrien clartryo qui est qui sont des
artistes de la région mais qui sont qui
sont à niveau exceptionnel voilà donc en
gros on a tout ce qu'il faut ici pour
faire bien et voir peut-être mieux qu'à
Paris et dans des conditions techniques
d'accueil du public largement meilleur
souvent que les salles parisiennes et
bien merci beaucoup
d'avoir répondu à nos questions et puis
surtout d'avoir de nous avoir accueilli
sur cette scène théâtre à Élancourt donc
si vous souhaitez en savoir plus sur la
nouvelle saison culturelle aux prismes
ne manquez pas la retransmission de la
soirée entracte c'est à 20h30 sur notre
antenne